Tom Verducci Sports Illustrated senior
baseball writer major league baseball
Network analyst he's covering the Cubs
Mets tomorrow on the MLB Network angels
Red Sox on Saturday let's start with the
Mets pitching issues here I think there
was a buyer beware with how hard these
guys throw is it as simple as that that
these are all guys with tommy john
surgery and here we are more issues for
them well not just that bad a pitch that
seventh month last year going all the
way the World Series and most of them
hadn't pitched a six month uh we see the
time and time again before the season
started I wrote something about hey
remember the old for America Marlins
remember that 03 Marla seen a great
young pitching staff with led by Josh
Beckett they hit a wall the next year
after they were pushed that far right I
talked to Jacob degrom who still doesn't
have a day plus fastball he's healthy
but he doesn't have the same velocity
and he said it's the innings man you
know it's a shorter offseason sort of
recovery period as well the Clayton
Kershaw situation with his back what did
the Dodgers know about that well he's
gonna get checked out today out in LA
we'll know a lot more but just something
that's been bothering him for a couple
of weeks that would be concerning to me
because clearly they've been aware of it
and been treating it probably with
anti-inflammatories and has a positive
response so I listen any kind of injury
with a pitcher you worried about how
does it change the mechanics and
certainly with Kershaw who's the gold
standard I actually think of all time
and I think he's on the greatest
pitching route of all time you're not
going to take any chances so you've got
the all-star break coming up and as much
as I know he would love to start his
first all-star game uh now may be the
time to back off a little bit all time
yeah I say that because you know I'm not
going to count Walter Johnson message at
ball era um but in terms of Pedro Randy
Johnson and Sandy Koufax the volume of
what this guy is doing for 2 230 is a
year and that strikeout to walk rate is
just crazy here's my best bet on Clayton
I think even pitching down
for eight years his career he ra has
lowered every single year I think he
just keeps getting better that supposed
to happen when you pitch as much as he
does but how is this happening that you
have so many great pictures but you'll
have this surge in home runs okay where
did this pitching come from that that
all of a sudden we're tuning in to watch
pitchers not hitters well the game on
every level especially the amateur level
is being driven by D'Lo everybody wants
a lawsuit is being chased and earlier
age you see the average velocity keep
going up the major leagues I said what
you're seeing now is starting pitchers
used to be able to pitch through a
lineup three times are now taking a
relievers mentality when I get the ball
and that is I go as far as I can for as
long as I can um and there's no hey let
me let that hold back a little bit the
first time around the lineup change
speeds a little bit no I mean it's a
pretty much max effort so I think what's
happening here though hitters realize it
man you have to a Trevor Bauer the
Indian someone who turned me on to this
a couple years ago what pictures are
doing essentially is the equivalent of
lowering the hoop and basketball or
shrinking the field in football I mean
it still 60 feet six inches between the
Reverend home plate but drawing as hard
as they do what they're doing is they're
shrinking that pissed so a hitter has
less time to read and react now what
does that mean you gotta sell out and
that's why we're seeing an
all-or-nothing game a lot of strikeouts
a lot of home runs speaking of pitching
and these guys throwing as hard as they
can for as long as they can what about
this idea that lets say i can have
clayton kershaw work three days a week
but maybe he's only throwing 50 or 60
pitches each start so we see the numbers
as you go through the lineup the
averages usually go up so if I have
Kershaw going through the lineup let's
say twice and then you bring in somebody
else so we're using more pitchers but
we're using them less with their
appearances can you ever see a situation
where starters our own I can use Kershaw
three days a week or a Jake Arrieta
uh either makes a lot of sense logically
the only problem is pitchers are not
going to get the things i get them money
wins and innings I think we're actually
heading in a completely opposite
direction I now we talk about normal
rest exactly more starts now in today's
game made on five days of rest and four
days of rest and you see that's what the
Mets are doing with their guys Cubs are
doing this around the all-star break
with their older pitchers I think we're
actually headed more towards the
Japanese model you know they don't play
on mondays over there it's the least
attended game of the week I would like
to see baseball go to 154 game schedule
everybody's off on Monday except for one
game which is a true national showcase
game and then you go to the Japanese
model where you're pitching as Tanaka
did and everybody else over there so
you're the Friday pictured well you're
the Saturday picture and you're picking
once a week and then you could pitch
deep burning two games because you have
more recovery I think we'd have a better
product Willie owners give up eight
dates you know that's been a big
sticking point all along I think they
should especially when you're talking
about monday nights early and late in
the season what schools in session Tom
Verducci joining us MLB Network Analyst
he's got Cubs Mets tomorrow angels Red
Sox on Saturday why the jump in home
runs you know I did my homework on this
and I consulted with some of the top
physicists in the world and there's
actually a very scientific name for this
freaky ah it makes no sense this is now
two years in a row of double-digit
increase in home runs now the only other
time that's happened in baseball history
there's a clear reason why it's happened
expansion in 93 players coming back from
war in the 40s on the ball the 1920s the
lowering amount in 1969 there's nothing
that's changed at least to an obvious I
with the game in the last couple of
years but it started the second half of
last season a tremendous spike late in
the year there's only two years in
baseball history we're home runs and
they're flying out as often as they are
this year and that's 19 99 and 2000 we
all know what was happening back then in
terms of the pharmacology in the game
it is really freaky it's not like
there's a bunch of hits lying around and
to me hormones are great i know people
love and fan but i would be a little bit
concerned you know i used to play game
with my brothers and you know you
probably did this to you paint a strike
zone while somewhere probably at the
school right you try to strike the guy
out and it's either a strikeout a walk
or a home run you don't need a defense
you don't need base runners the game is
too much of that these days too much
strikeout walk home run we're not saying
an increase really in run scoring or in
burley stolen bases or hits we're just
seeing a one-dimensional increase and
that's at home runs but I also think the
velocity has something to do with it is
well that when you do connect you you
are going to hit a home run and I don't
know if the fact that everybody throws
95 now has something to do with that
well it's interesting I do think there
is something to do with that but you got
to be careful about that old saw that
you know the harder it comes in the
harder it goes out because now that we
do have the last couple of years that
cast to measure basically everything in
play some of the longest home runs have
been hit on off speed pitches so it's
not a direct correlation I do think
though what we talked about in terms of
velocity we've got to get started sooner
and sell out for velocity you can't read
and react I do think velocity correlates
to hold on that regard before I let you
go the Pete Rose situation why did it
take this long to get into the Reds Hall
of Fame and does this mean anything for
baseball's hall of fame law doesn't mean
anything for baseball hall of fame I I
don't know what the rich people were
thinking maybe they were hoping that
Pete had this outside chance but getting
into Cooperstown and he could be welcome
to the Reds Hall of Fame is a true Hall
of Famer I mean clearly we all know he
should have been in the red ball thing
at least you know that place open but I
think even the reg realize now that that
door is pretty much closed field and
locked so it was time to put him in on
this date I'm gonna put you on the spot
you got more confidence in the Cubs or
the Giants oh that is on the spot
because i think the Cubs have the better
team but to me the Giants are the
biggest obstacle in the way between the
Cubs internationally pennant I mean a
giant we all
how they play in postseason baseball yet
they don't have to hit home runs to win
games they're a little bit of an anomaly
there I will still tell you I will go
with the Cubs for this reason I am
assuming that between now and August
first the Cubs are going to go out and
get someone like Andrew Miller it's the
one flaw in this team that they don't
have a lockdown relief pitcher in the
back of the game especially left-handed
and you can't tell me the way they build
this team but otherwise the best roster
baseball all these years of waiting that
they're going to go into October with
that one flaw that everybody knows about
so I'm assuming that they will get you
know whether it's Miller or Chapman or
somebody else I'm talking about an elite
guy at the back end of the game thank
you Tom safe travels all I can pleasure
dad take care that's a ton Verducci the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience